No I need to know pokerface is that bad
cool please why did you keep this from
us I think I made a big big mistake hey
everybody its charlie they did a big CW
panel this morning where they talked
about Flash Batman
Batwoman arrow the big crossover episode
so I'm gonna break this down top-10
style there was just so much information
that they gave us so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's a new round
of that flash ring giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video
starting with number 10
Caitlin's mother and father are coming
back to the show we've already met her
mother during season 3 and she talked
all about her backstory during season 2
but the big deal is that her father is
coming back that was what that big
flashback scene was at the end of season
4 like they were teeing up a moment with
her father a memory so he's gonna
continue to develop that storyline of
her origin into season 5 it's gonna be
all about how she got her powers but
number 9 there's this whole untold
secret history where her father has been
this whole time he's a scientist just
like Caitlin and her mother the way the
description of her father reads is that
he's been gone for a long time he just
showed up like remember when Oliver
Queen was thought dead for five years
when he was on Lian Yu it's a situation
with her father like he's been gone
nobody knows where he's been and he just
shows up one day so way back during the
reverse-flash returns episode during
season two she revealed that he had died
from multiple sclerosis when she was a
little girl so apparently that was a
super big lie no idea why her mother may
not have known about this or lied to her
about it because during season 3 we got
all those scenes with her where she was
starting to express her killer frost
persona her mother seemed like she
didn't really know what was going on but
if she's as smart as she came off then
there was probably something going on
during her childhood and her mother was
lying to her this whole time her father
was lying to her
so major arcs of season 5 Barry getting
to know his daughter and helping her fix
her big problem but for Caitlin it's
gonna be learning all about her origin
in the true history of her family she
had her powers as a little girl so
either she was born with them meaning
that her father would be a metahuman
or her mother and father did something
to her when they were conceiving her or
when she was young that gave her her
powers
that's gonna be what she'll learn over
the course of these 23 episodes number 8
this is a big one they've changed the
structure of the show the way episodes
play out so now what's going to happen
is is that you'll have little pods of
people in different places so imagine
you have all of team flash all the main
characters you split them up during
episodes into small little groups so
iris will be doing reporter iris stuff
off by herself with a couple of the
people Barry will be doing team flash
stuff with Nora like he would usually be
doing then you have Caitlin doing killer
frost stuff and support stuff when
needed so people will float around from
group to group
but it'll be a bunch of different people
all over the place instead of everybody
being in STAR Labs in scenes all at the
same time every single episode this is a
clip of Candice Patton talking about
that the audio is a little janky but the
information is really good
which I'm very excited about it
visually indistinctly audience
so they're just a number of reasons why
it's good that they're changing the way
they do stories like this episode 1 2 3
it'll be pretty evident why stories work
a lot better when you do stuff this way
number 7 a lot of you asking me about
Cisco what's going on with him there is
some evidence that they're feeding him
to the villain wood chipper and the
first half of the season
aka cicada just to make him feel like a
bigger threat the first half of the
season that is that doesn't mean that
he's leaving the show completely but
there was this post that iris had in the
background here this is a blog post that
almost reads vibe dead and they haven't
even gotten close to filming episode 7
or 8 yet so this is pretty early in the
season the actor that plays Cisco is
still a main character on the show he
hasn't left as far as we know
so was probably going on is that they're
trading on the nostalgia of season 1
remember one of the biggest moments from
season 1 was when reverse flash killed
Cisco and they brought him right back so
what they might be doing is as part of
Nora's mistakes storyline listen team
flash would be making a lot of mistakes
one of those leads to the death of Cisco
it makes cicada feel like a much bigger
threat because he's taken down one of
the big characters then they start
fixing mistakes later in the season and
that brings Cisco back there's a little
bit of speculation there just based on
the idea that Cisco is still on the TV
show but it seems like they're killing
him early on so if he's dead but he's
still a main character on the show that
just means that he's coming back soon
but number 6 just explaining Nora's
mistakes they confirmed that Nora and
team flash would continue to make a lot
of big WTF mistakes as they start to
deal with the cicada villain like Nora
says the beginning of this I think I
made a big mistake Nora how could you
keep this from us they find out what
Nora's initial mistakes were there were
a couple it's not any one particular
mistake then as they encounter cicada
they continue to make more mistakes but
obviously the whole idea is that they
fix things
typically the finales have pretty happy
ending so eventually they'll fix
everything but not before things get
really really bad for them in the first
half of the season
speaking of which number five there was
a little bit of confusion over the
hundredth episode of this big tcas panel
Mark Pedowitz who's one of the head
people at CW was giving out all this
information he said some confusing
things but then backtracked so just
confirmation that episode 9 this year of
all the show
is going to be the crossover episode
with Batwoman episode 8 the hundredth
episode of the flash will be its own
special thing number 4 speaking of
Batwoman they confirm Batman exists on
earth 1 because of that Oliver Queen
name drop now Oliver Queen mentioned
Bruce Wayne
so all that did last year was confirmed
that Bruce Wayne exists but Mark
Pedowitz was like yes Batman exists on
earth 1 so we know that he is around
somewhere
he lives in Gotham City but they said
that the crossover episode would not
feature that character at all so no
Batman no Bruce Wayne the only said he
wouldn't appear they didn't say they
wouldn't reference him because you have
to make that connection with bat woman
she's flying around town wearing his
symbol on her chest so just expect them
to talk about Batman don't expect to see
him 3 the Batwoman TV showed that
they're developing will film its pilot
early next year but it has not been
picked up to series yet so it would have
to be a terrible terrible pilot in order
to not be picked up so it's a pretty
easy slam-dunk for this team meaning
that they would start filming the
regular episodes during the summer it
would premiere during the fall number 2
they followed up with talk about shows
being canceled from the arrowverse
because some of them have been on air
for a long time now this is the just
because they're doing the Batwoman TV
show they have 6 nights of programming
to fill that's a lot they used to only
do 5 so like they need a bunch of extra
shows so they said just because they're
doing that woman doesn't automatically
mean that they're gonna cancel arrow or
legends of tomorrow or Supergirl or any
of the less rated CW DC TV shows so
going into the season nothing is on the
chopping block right now like they
haven't confirmed anything they don't
make renewals till around February March
April of next year so it'll be at least
another eight or nine months before we
find out about the future of what's
going on with this universe so I
wouldn't worry about any of the shows
getting canceled anytime soon in number
one this is actually a pretty big deal
while I was making this video Warner
Brothers announced that it's developing
a Supergirl
movie now this is set within the DC
Universe meaning that would involve
Henry cavils Man of Steel character so
they haven't said anything about what
the story would be how they would invoke
her because Zack Snyder did actually
write a version of Supergirl into a
prequel tie-in story for the
Man of Steel movie but that was so long
ago and it wasn't really a part of the
actual movie it was part of like this
tie-in comic book so it's always kind of
questionable about how that stuff's
canon or not Canon I would just expect a
soft reboot to the way that universe has
treated the Supergirl character and when
they do this movie they'll just find a
way to explain how she shows up while
Clark Kent has been running around on
planet earth this whole time they just
hired a writer to develop it so bare
minimum it'll be 2 to 3 years before
this movie ever hits theaters if
everything goes well meaning this
Supergirl the TV show might almost be
off the air so I don't think there's
gonna be any sort of crossover issues
and I don't expect Melyssa to be a part
of the movie but let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
all this now this was a CW panel so they
didn't say anything about Titans or
Young Justice season 3 or any of the
other DC shows that are gonna be on the
streaming service so there'll be more
videos for that stuff coming up pretty
soon but just leave all your requests in
the comments below but what'll happen is
is I'll name a new giveaway winner when
I post new DC click here for that flash
hundred episode video and click here for
brand new Avengers 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]